there may or may not be a sequence in
this movie where I'm in Rob plays a
washed-up jiggler trying to woo a
wealthy over woman played by Raquel
Welch but he's got some competition
Mexican comedian Eugenio devez plays
Rob's rival and Friends I can only
imagine what some of the costuming is
like all my shirts are open till here
yeah this is the moneymaker I am so
proud of okay I'm like everybody this
guy keep your eyes on him Salma Hayek is
eugenio's on-screen sister he's not a
very positive influence in my son and
while the men get a lot of attention
Salma says don't underestimate the
ladies meeting ladies
that's extraordinary and they get to be
sexy and sassy and bald and funny and
crazy like Kristen Bell who joins the
cast as a crazy singing cat lady welcome
to my home it's a really fun character
because she's she has a lot of cats
she's compassionate towards anything sad
or lonely or in distress stay here as
long as you like I'm sure you'll find a
way to pay me back
stealing the show eight-year-old Raphael
Alejandro who clearly doesn't need any
help when it comes to the ladies I think
that if a woman likes you should like
you for who you are not for a loser
pretending to be can I take you home
with me at the chapel
you